HAVE A CLUE, YOU ARE NOT GOING
TO BE THE GREAT BREAKDANCER YOU
THINK YOU ARE.
YOU ARE GOING TO DESTROY YOUR
BODY BEFORE YOU GET UP INTO THE
LITTLE ASIANS LEVEL.
>> LITTLE ASIANS, SEEMS
REDUNDANT.
THAT B-BUOY IS ALEX.
I HEARD BREAKDANCER IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS
NEXT TO DECORATING PUBLIC
PROPERTY INTO SPRAY PAINT.
IT IS GYMNASTIC FOR PEOPLE WHO
CAN'T AFFORD PROPER TRAINING.
I REFUSE TO LAY MY BODY ON THE
DISGUSTING FLOOR.
THIS SHIRT COST $900.
YEAH, HIGH FASHIONED.
I KNOW TO LOCK MY CAR DOOR WHEN
EVER PEOPLE ARE DOING IT.
I AM FROM FLORIDA YOU KNOW I CAN
TOOT SI ROLL.
I HAVE NEVER KRIP WALKED.
I GREW UP IN A GOOD SED.
MINORITIES ARE BETTER AT
BREAKDANCER.
THERE ARE FEWER PARENTS TO
SQUASH THEIR PASSION.
WHITES ARE NOT THE BEST AT THIS
ONE PARTICULAR ACTIVITY.
WE CONTROL THE WORLD ECONOMY.
I AM OKAY FOR LETTING ANOTHER
RACE HAVE KRUMPING.
MICHAEL J. FOX DID LEAVE
TELEVISION TO PURSUE TELEVISION
FULL TIME.
ALEX STILL THINKS HE CAN DANCE.
HE PLAYS CRAWLING WITH LITTLE
ASIANS IN THIS WEEK'S WEB
REDEMPTION.
>> DANIEL, YOUR BOYFRIEND IS
HERE.
>> COME IN, HAVE A SEAT.
MAYBE I CAN GET YOU SOMETHING.
MAYBE A WATCH.
>> YOU'LL NEVER BE AS FUNNY AS
THOSE LITTLE JEWS.
>> I WILL THEN I WILL SHOVE IT
IN YOUR -- FACE.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN DANCING?
>> YEAH.
I TRIED FOOTBALL, MY DAD PUSHED
ME INTO PLAYING BASKETBALL.
>> VERY FEW DADS PUSH THEIR BOYS
INTO B-BOYING.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE HIT ME
UP ON YOUTUBE AND SAID SHE IS A
RACIST, BITCH.
IN THE VIDEO SHE IS WORRIED
ABOUT MY HEALTH BECAUSE I KEEP
HURTING MYSELF.
>> THEN SHE THROUGH AN ENTIRE
RACE OF PEOPLE THROUGH THE BUS.
WHEN MY PARENTS SAW IT WASN'T A
FAD, A THING TO GET GIRLS.
>> IT IS STILL JUST TO GET
GIRLS, RIGHT?
MY ENTIRE EXISTENCE IS FOR
WOMEN.
I GOT INTO COMEDY FOR GIRLS.
>> THE QUICKEST WAY TO A GIRL IS
HER FUNNY BONE.
>> IT IS NOT TRUE, IT IS MONEY.
>> I AM IN A CREW.
>> DID YOU GET BEAT IN OR SEXED
IN.
>> WHAT RACE IS THE BEST
DANCERS?
>> KOREA AND JAPAN.
>> SMEAR NUMBERS GAME.
SO MANY OF THOSE LITTLE
BASTARDS.
WHEN YOU ARE AT A NIGHTCLUB, HOW
QUICK BEFORE YOU TAKE OVER?
>> POST UP AGAINST THE WALL,
WATCH PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU SEE SOMEONE ELSE, I
COULD SMACK HIM.
YOU JUMP UP AND PROVE YOU ARE
BETTER.
>> I POST UP AND BE THE CREEPY
GUY.
WHENEVER YOU ARE MAKING LOVE,
HAVE YOU SPUN OVER ON THEM?
>> IF YOU ARE A B-BOW YOU CAN
WANT.
>> WOULD YOU DATE JAY-LO?
>> YES.
>> I WOULDN'T>> WHY?
>> FIRST OF ALL SHE IS
DISGUSTING.
>> TELL ME THREE NICE THINGS
THAT AREN'T RACIST ABOUT ASIANS?
>> I LOVE ASIAN FOOD.
>> I WATCH -- MARSHAL ARTS.
>> DO YOU THINK IT IS COOL THAT
THEY PEE PEE IN OUR COKE?
>> NO.
>> I HAVE FLOWN YOUR MOTHER OUT
HERE.
YOUR MOM AND A GROUP OF 25 PAID
EXTRAS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> YES.
>> MOM, ARE YOU READY NOT TO SAY
ANYTHING RACIST FOR THE NEXT 2
MINUTES?
>> SURE.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE].
>> THANKS.
WHAT THE HELL ARE THOSE LITTLE
ASIANS DOING HERE?
[LAUGHTER].
>> DANCE BATTLE.
>> TURNS OUT YOUR MOM WAS SPOT
ON.
♪ ♪
>> DANCE LIKE NO ONE IS
WATCHING.
EVERYONE IS WATCHING THAT ASIAN
CREW.
♪ ♪
NICE.
THERE IS NO WAY YOU LOST THIS.
[APPLAUSE].
>> DON'T FEEL BAD, YOU'LL NEVER
BE AS GOOD AS THOSE GANG MEMBERS